- Maybe my biggest
worry, which is like what
if I really, really, really
love this and I have to
come back like every week
to get my ass steamed or
my life won't be right.
(upbeat music)
- Hi, I'm Nikki from Tikkun Holistic Spa.
We're gonna have gentlemen do a treatment
called the A Steam which is literally
a steamer for your anal area.
- Like the higher it goes, like the rating
gets like more inappropriate.
It's like, uh oh, we're a PG13 now.
- Oh, we've known each
other for seven years
and I think it's time for us to get
our buttholes steamed together and really
becomes butthole brother.
- Are these washable?
They wash these.
- Have they washed these?
- We've known each for multiple years.
- For a multiple (mumbling).
- We're pretty close, we're good friends.
- We're bad at (mumbling).
- Went to college together.
- She was saying earlier that it's like
drinking tea except like through your ass.
- I feel like it's
gonna bring us together.
- They'll be sitting
on this beautiful chair
and the steam of the Chinese herbs will
be actually going up their perineal area.
The steam will help
give them a good detox.
- [Voiceover] You guys excited?
- Yeah, yeah, we're excited and scared.
(humming)
- Oh my god, I'm actually
terrified, I'm terrified.
(laughing)
- I think we're supposed
to use our Sleep Numbers.
(beeping)
- Oh, this is not good.
- Get out.
- The only thing that's
weird is like literally
it's like my butthole.
- It's really great for hemorrhoids.
It's good for any kind of stomach issues.
- Mm hmm.
She said if you go to a
10 it's like gonna boil.
- Apparently if you turn it all the way up
it quote, "boils your balls."
It's like honestly the weirdest sensation,
but it's not unpleasant.
- I guess this is a feeling
that humans can have.
- Do buttholes sweat?
- The buttholes do sweat a lot.
- Great for hormonal acne
and balancing your hormones.
- It's not that I'm disappointed.
But when I signed up for
this I expected like,
(whooshing)
- Go with a friend, go up to 10.
That's my two major pieces
of advice for an A Steam.
- I think you have to do this with someone
that you're comfortable with.
- Butthole steamin' might be my new thing.
- If we had these thrones,
we would be on them
for a half hour every day.
- I've never been more
proud of my butthole.
- I'm not gonna lie, I
think this did nothing
but bring us even closer.
- This might be a new thing
we do on the weekends.
- To our buttholes.
- To the next level.
- Yes.
- Can we trade?
- Yeah.
- Aw man, this is like a
workout for my butthole.
(howling)
- That's good, I'll just turn that down.
I'll turn that down.